et les Britanniques grands soutien des
Ukrainiens dégaines aussi des sanctions
Londres vise également les banques mais
aussi des oligarques Boris Johnson se
dit prêt à aller plus loin en cas de
nouvelles escalade militaires et ça et
c'est un peu la position des Américains
bonjour Sonia dready on vous retrouve à
Washington Joe Biden a annoncé un
premier train de sanction mais il
l'adaptera en fonction de l'évolution de
la situation
oui la Maison Blanche doit annoncer
aujourd'hui de nouvelles sanctions déjà
ce matin la porte-parole de la Maison
Blanche à saluer la suspension par
l'Allemagne de l'autorisation du gazoduc
North stream 2 hier soir le président
Joe Biden a publié un décret pour
interdire tout nouvel investissement ou
financement par des personnes
américaines à destination ou en
provenance des régions séparatistes
prorus d'Ukraine alors certains
s'attendaient à des sanctions plus
sévères de la part des États-Unis et
hier soir un officiel de la Maison
Blanche à fournit un début d'explication
il a assuré que la décision du président
russe d'envoyer des soldats pour une
opération qualifiée de maintien de la
paix dans les régions séparatistes
prorus d'Ukraine et bien ne constituez
pas une invasion supplémentaire du pays
ce sont des territoires que la Russie
contre les déjà a-t-il dit et c'est pour
ça qu'il n'y a pas eu de plus vaste
sanctions américaines mais en réalité
une maison blanche joue la prudence et
joue sur les mots parce que ce matin un
membre du Conseil de sécurité nationale
a dit qu'on assistait au début du
invasion la Maison Blanche espère
finalement pouvoir que la situation soit
contenue dans le dans basse mais elle
dit redouter une une invasion
d'envergure de l'Ukraine et d'ailleurs
l'administration Biden a prévu qui a
prévenu qu'il y aurait d'autres
sanctions qui ont déjà été discutées
avec les alliés en cas d'invasion de
l'Ukraine les élus républicains déjà
demandent plus de fermeté à l'égard de
la Russie et aujourd'hui le débat
Washington c'est finalement qu'est-ce
qu'une invasion de l'Ukraine merci Sonia
Dre